hello hi Dean are you doing very good
thank you and you very good the weather
is very warm here well not very warm but
compared to Russia it's warm because I
heard that in Russia it's very cold now
hopefully it's going to be a little bit
warmer when I get there - minus 10 and
today I have some questions for you I'd
like to ask you what do you do in your
life well it's it's a very general
question I work now I work as a language
consultant that it's a little bit
different from a language teacher in the
sense that I am a guide and I motivate
students to learn a language I show them
the path but they have to cover that
path you know there's a saying you can't
lead a horse to water you can lead a
horse to water but you can't make it
drink so what I do is I combine my you
know skills as an engineer I will call
it language engineering so to say with
my language skill so I to answer your
question I am working as a language
consultant online mm-hmm and also I know
that you learn languages foreign
languages yes I just I you know I train
people to learn the languages that I
know but I also learn languages you know
all the time and on a daily basis right
now I'm learning I'm actively learning
polish and Japanese languages can you
speak
the term speak speaking and languages is
a little bit vague you know if you want
to give it a proper definition I would
say that according to the common
European framework of reference for
languages that would be b1 I would say
that you know speaking the language
means to reach a more-or-less b1 level
at least and according to that
definition I would say that I speak ten
languages right now some at a higher
level some at a lower level but still we
won't be - at least
mm-hmm and I know that you have very
good pronunciation especially in Russian
some words you can talk without any
accent pronunciation well I I believe
that language is like a net I have
developed a what I call a top-down
approach that means that I mainly focus
on propel intonation
I work in chunks with the language I
don't start with words with the
pronunciation of single words but I work
on the overall overall phonetic fabric
of a language so I have developed the
capacity of acquiring a native like
pronunciation maybe not native but good
pronunciation by applying certain
technique so I believe that maybe a part
of it is a natural knack for accents or
disposition but I also believe that
anybody can acquire a very good
pronunciation if they use of the right
techniques mm-hmm and is it your ISO
technique or you from sound with you no
it's my technique it's my personal
technique I would say in the loop
technique but obviously you can you know
make use of books that talk about this
but I have developed this personally so
it's kind of it's not an invention it's
just something I have developed in the
course of you know in there in in the
years and I make it very practical
there's a lot of there's a dearth a
wealth of materials that talk about this
but it's very special istic so I make it
very practical and I train all my
students to do that and they are very
happy because it's something very
practical language is something
practical so if you train people to do
that
directly at that by attacking the
language they're more than happy to you
know go and go further if you if you
talk too much about theory that kind
they can discourage people from learning
a language so make it practical and make
it fun okay yeah I'm excited as well to
come to Russia of course
well the conference I'm going to talk to
I'm going to hold two speeches the first
speech is going to be about dispelling
common myths people believe for example
that learning language is difficult they
have no memory they have no talent etc
etc and then I will talk in the second
speech I will talk about some techniques
about methods and gentle I'll show that
there is no one best method but you have
to abide by certain cognitive principles
in order to learn a language effectively
that's more or less what I'm going to
talk about yes I I think that language
learning is something pragmatical so you
can talk about it in theory it's
interesting how the brain works but I
also believe that it's it's always very
good to show directly to people how to
do things and the training is going to
be all about that that means that I'm
going to teach people trade people which
is a better term trained people how to
use bilingual text monolingual text as
well as you know my technique in order
to grasp what I call the thematic fabric
of a language a means of training in
pronunciation and above all in
intonation very practical things yes
for what languages only for English the
you know the thing is that I teach I
trained people in five six languages but
in general you need just one language to
show how it works because it's pretty
universal so once you well every
languages has a different climatic
fabric and let's say but some principles
are a universal so if you learn how to
apply this technique to a one language
you can apply it to any other I have
never been to Russia and I'm very
excited because I'm going to see both
Moscow and st. Petersburg what he called
peach it so and I heard that they're
both beautiful cities so I'm very very
happy about that
it's a problem I heard that it's a very
very cold winter well it's not it's it's
unexpected it's a little bit special
this year but I'm going to get to come
prepared I'm going to buy you know a
warm coat let's prosecutors yeah we'll
have plenty of time I think okay thank
you dinner